I'm sure like you've never gone to
police whores actually I have oh I heard
it here first please like comment
subscribe thanks for watching
cut excellent love the energy today Ryan
have you been working out no consider
doing some quick reminder the All Hands
pre marketing meeting for the marketing
meeting is today so grab a quick bite
run up to the conference room Oh talk to
me what it's all feet shows our man you
can stop perfect
[Music]
March 23rd post about at a bus
stop was more popular than the March
15th post about at a doctor's
office this leads us to believe that bus
stops are funnier
while office escapes are inherently more
sexual given the levels of engagement
that's right big guy given me a meeting
fees you're doing great
they think you're engaged and nobody has
any idea you thinking about but really
in meeting fees and you can see oval
number one is small oval number two is
they bit bigger oval number three is
bigger still and four is the largest
oval so yo my name is Jordi you know I
like pizza loving on the girls they say
happy to meet you Pizza Pizza meetcha
what rhymes with pizza how about pizza
tell us the same word but it is Chris
thinking about boots what we launched
our new digital series high-priced fish
lawyers it circles around a group of
lawyers who work expensive fish related
cases who are also half-human half-fish
as I was saying before my own experience
Devin or was a Kevin Kevin is that even
a name Creve n' maybe he's Slovak uh-huh
even if I figure out his name what am I
gonna say hey so crazy we both come to
this hotdog stands every day
what are you doing waiter hmm he
probably thinks I'm gross for eating hot
dogs every day but like him he's
there too
god he's cute I think revin is my
soulmate oh my god
is Kevin my soulmate of course we have
done many graphs relating to the
effectiveness of company meetings my
favorite being the pie graph second
favorite is the bar graph oh my name is
Jordi and you know I like pizza
love it on the girls they say happy to
meet ya Pizza Pizza glad to meet ya yeah
Jonah's gonna be so happy when I tell
him about this rap song I've written for
him I'm such a good friend wait a minute
is Chris thinking about I knew that I
wanted to see my pop pop once more
before the harvest I was traditionally
the corn so then I end each episode by
saying something wacky but still
reminding people to LIKE and subscribe
it's a job but hey so what's the name of
your YouTube show again every damn day
very inspiring very insightful you know
Nathan just keep being you I'm Barack
Obama and I don't think your palms are
too sweaty the president on this slide
it was the coldest winter on record and
I knew that I had to pull that trigger
because my family didn't have enough oil
to heat our stove I'm Jordan I'm a fart
boy lol I think Ryan is so cool but I'd
never tell him because that'd be bad for
my image I'm Natasha I'm so weird
I think I'll microwave some fish and
then not eat it for some reason
I'm Chris I can always wear whatever I
want but Ryan has to change his shirt
because that looks too much like a
swastika I'm Hannah I love to fry it
you've been talking out loud this entire
time what the is wrong with you
we've been inner monologue dude not
outer
that's when it all came crashing down I
could tell I lost the respect to my
co-workers even if I secretly did think
they're go we can still hear you bro
[Music]
you